[MUSIC PLAYING]
JONATHAN GRUBER: I think
the main thing an economics
course can do in
this day and age
is get people to be a little
more flexible, a little more
thoughtful about
decisions they make,
and seeing both
sides of the problem.
SARAH HANSEN: Today
in the podcast:
seeing economics in
a whole new light.
JONATHAN GRUBER:
I've had application,
a course about
demand and supply,
about Kim Kardashian
tweeting herself
out a picture of
an exercise corset,
and that increased demand
for exercise corsets.
And so thinking about how
something, where students
can see it and
say, "Wow, I hadn't
realized that economics help
me think about that problem."
SARAH HANSEN: Welcome
to Chalk Radio,
a podcast about inspired
teaching at MIT.
I'm your host, Sarah Hansen,
from MIT OpenCourseWare.
In this episode, we'll be
talking about the course 14.01
Introductory Microeconomics.
This course is filled
with unique and creative
applications for microeconomics
in our everyday lives.
I'll be chatting today with
the creator of this course,
Professor Jon Gruber.
One of the things I was
most excited to find out
was the way people
perceive economics.
So I asked Professor Gruber
what misconceptions students
tend to bring to this class.
JONATHAN GRUBER:
That's a good question.
I think they tend to perceive
it as maybe softer than it is,
maybe not perceive
that you're going
to derive fairly
sharp tools that
are going to help you explain a
lot of the world fairly easily.
Then, on the other
hand, they often
come with expectations that
we'll explain more of the world
than we can.
SARAH HANSEN: So
how do you help them
address these misconceptions?
JONATHAN GRUBER: I think
by just being honest
about the limitations and
benefits of our models,
by explaining the power
that our models can
deliver in fairly simple
terms in explaining
a lot of the world.
But at the same
time, representing
the things the models
can't easily explain
and being honest
about that and trying
to get students interested
in studying more economics
that can explain
those things as well.
I don't expect most
viewers of my videos
to go on to get a PhD in
economics, unfortunately.
I expect they're going to
go out and have other jobs,
do other things, and I want them
to be more educated consumers
of news and to understand what's
going on in the world in terms
of economic policy.
SARAH HANSEN: Could we talk
a minute about the real world
applications?
JONATHAN GRUBER: OK.
SARAH HANSEN: It's a really
interesting part of the course.
You have LeBron James's college
decision, the Uber surge
pricing.
Tell us about your
decision to really anchor
the course with these
real world applications.
JONATHAN GRUBER: It's
what makes economics fun.
Once again, I'm
not training people
to be economics PhDs here.
I'm training people to
think like an economist,
and thinking like an
economist, if you've
got a very facile
mind and you look
at the basic theory
videos I teach you,
you can understand it.
But you only really
understand something
when you go in the real
world and apply it.
And so it's a chance for people
to see the ways that economics
rules the world but
to also sort of apply
what they've learned to make
sure they understand it.
SARAH HANSEN: What
tips for educators
do you have about selecting
really good applications?
JONATHAN GRUBER:
I think it's just
a matter of trying to find
examples in the real world that
are relatable.
Companies they've heard of
and issues they think about
and that-- in a not
necessarily obvious way--
teach you about the
lessons you want to learn.
I've had application, the
course about demand and supply,
about Kim Kardashian
tweeting herself
out a picture of
an exercise corset,
and that increased demand
for exercise corsets.
And so thinking about how
something where students
can see it and
say, wow, I hadn't
realized economics helped
me think about that problem.
SARAH HANSEN: Professor Gruber's
passion for economics is clear,
and I wanted to get
to the bottom of it.
Why does he care so much
about helping others
find their passion
for economics,
and how did his own
curiosity begin?
JONATHAN GRUBER: I
came to MIT knowing
that I was good at math,
but I didn't really like it.
What I liked was real world
social policy types of issues,
and I took 14.01
and said, oh my god,
I can use math to apply
to the real world.
Isn't this cool?
And I've been hooked ever since.
Many of your listeners
will not realize
that there was a
time when we used
to talk to people
next to us on a plane,
before we had smartphones.
And every time I fly in a plane
and tell the person next to me
I was an economics
professor, they'd say, oh,
that was the worst course
I ever took, and I thought,
that can't be true.
It might not be the
best, but there's
no way it could be the worst
course someone ever took.
I realized it just was generally
badly taught in our school
systems, and so I
was always interested
in trying to address that.
But I think really,
where I really
want to go is figure out a
way to write better problems.
It's easy to write a problem
with a mathematical solution:
"The firm has the following
production functions.
Solve for their
profit maximization."
It's harder to
write problems that
involve math but also
derive intuition,
and that's really
where I want to go
is, help students bridge
that link between solving
equations and understanding
why they're doing it
and what they're
learning from it.
SARAH HANSEN: I just want to
talk about that a little bit
more, because you're not
the first MIT faculty
member to really want
to hone in on intuition.
And I'm just
wondering, like how do
we develop students'
intuition, because I'm
sure educators out there
in all sorts of fields
are wanting to do this too.
Is it something that's developed
over time in a field and just
with experience,
or is it something
we can cultivate as teachers?
JONATHAN GRUBER: I think that it
is something we can cultivate.
I think that it comes from not
assuming people know things
they don't know.
It comes from
teaching in layers.
So that if there's
a set of things
I teach that I'd be
really disappointed
if not everyone came out
with intuition from my class,
there's other more
subtle concepts
that if not everyone remembers
them, understands them,
then that's not the
end of the world.
But I'd like students who want
to go on to be like, oh, that's
interesting.
I want to go down that path.
So I think it's really about
getting the things that you
really want people to
know, hammering them,
but the other thing I like
that I do in my class is really
always have a constant roadmap.
I always tell the students,
OK, here's where we came from.
Here's where we're going.
Here's where it fits in.
So they can have
a holistic sense
of how it all fits together.
SARAH HANSEN: In
our conversation,
I asked Professor
Gruber what he believes
educators can do practically
to transfer problems
from the classroom into the real
world, and his answer touched
on a point that is
coming into play
all over our modern world--
the complexity and truth
about, well, truth.
JONATHAN GRUBER: I think the
main number one thing is just
to teach a healthy respect
for the scientific method,
to teach students that
there are objective truths
and that there is this long
standing scientific method
for how we get at them.
The other thing,
however, is to recognize
that there are two sides
of almost every issue.
And that this is something
that a lot of students at MIT
sometimes have
problems with my class
which is it's not just an
equation with one right answer.
There's pros and cons to
a lot of these things.
So I think it's teaching a
search for the objective truth
that can help you come to the
conclusion that works for you.
That there's not necessarily
one right answer.
You and I might
disagree about a topic,
but we should agree on
an objective set of facts
and have a scientific method
for getting to our conclusion.
I think that's the key-- in
today's world especially--
that's the key is
just getting people
to have a healthy
disagreement rather
than an unhealthy disagreement.
SARAH HANSEN: One of the most
compelling parts of this course
is how it emphasizes ways to
carry its concepts forward
into the real world.
Students are given
specific pathways
they might follow in
their career or lives
outside of school, where
they can use these concepts.
This was something really
important to Professor Gruber,
and I wanted to know why.
JONATHAN GRUBER: I
feel that economics
is enormously powerful.
I'm what you might call an
imperialistic economist.
I feel like
economics can explain
lots of things in the world,
and there's very few situations
where a good economic framework
can't help you at least go
forward in thinking about it.
And I don't want students
to just take the AP test
and forget about
it, quite frankly.
I want this to be something
they bring with them
and actually keep with them.
There's a famous old
Saturday Night Live
skit about what you remember
five years after college,
and it's five minutes, and
three and a half minutes of it
is spring break.
I want them to try to have
a basic set of intuitions
that they can understand can
apply to decisions they're
going to make about how
much to save in their 401(k)
to how hard to work,
to what car to choose,
to how to buy a
house, et cetera.
And quite frankly,
to me personally,
how to vote and think about
public policy, a set of tools
that they can bring
to bear on thinking
about these important
problems in America today.
One slight difficulty we
have is a lot of students
come in much too determined
and set in their ways
in what they're going to do.
I'm going to be an engineer.
I'm going to be a
computer scientist,
and they're often
not flexible enough.
So part of I view my
job, and a lot of times
when they're taking
economics, they're just
taking it because they have to.
And my job is to get them to
say, hey, I actually like this,
and I love nothing more when
I get an email from a student
saying, wow, I wasn't even
going to study economics.
But I like your course, and
want to major in economics.
That was wonderful, but
I also want the student
that is not going to
major in economics
to several years later
saying, hey, yeah,
that's something I can
relate what I learned
in economics to how I
think about that problem,
and that could
help me in my life.
Microeconomics is
basic economics.
Macroeconomics is
essentially applied micro.
It's basically
about every decision
we make, every
decision firms make,
can all be informed
by economic framework,
and that can be informed in a
particularly healthy way today.
Because the economic
framework really
is about trade-offs
and about thinking
the fact that nothing's
easy, everything
involves pros and
cons and trade-offs,
and there's shades of gray
to every decision we make.
And I think the main thing
an economics course can
do in this day and age is get
people to be a little more
flexible, a little
more thoughtful
about decisions
they make and seeing
both sides of the problem.
SARAH HANSEN: If you're
interested in learning more
about microeconomics or viewing
his real world application
videos, you can visit Professor
Gruber's interactive online MIT
course on edX.
To access his full
lecture videos
from his on-campus
teaching, head over
to his scholar course on
our site at ocw.mit.edu.
You'll also find 20 plus
additional courses just
on microeconomics on OCW.
If you're an instructor, head on
over to the OCW Educator Portal
at ocw.mit.edu/educator to
find resources just for you.
Thanks for listening.
Until next time, I'm Sarah
Hansen from MIT OpenCourseWare.
[MUSIC PLAYING]